je décourage les jeunes de venir c'est
pas la peine qu'un soupçon
si son salarié qui reste salarié coup de
gueule d'un kiosquiers parisiens c'était
en 2002 le métier se meurt il n'attire
plus il est loin bien loin le temps où
la profession séduisent et c'était dans
les années 80 une époque où les
parisiens acheter les journaux
c'est un métier très gai très attrayant
étant donné que nous voyons beaucoup de
monde et différentes personnes de toutes
sortes la vie et gens viennent voir les
nouvelles et où il ya du passage et les
gens viennent coiffer vous demande du
pape chez nous à partir des années 90 le
kiosque à journaux invention
haussmannienne disparaît petit à petit
du paysage parisien
peu de candidats à la reprise faibles
salaires conditions de travail
difficiles et puis le mauvais temps
n'aide pas la profession
on a envie de faire autre chose qui
toute sa vie toute sa vie peut-être pas
non non ça va un moment et puis
attention le changer quand même pourquoi
c'est dur comme du début des années 2000
les kiosquiers doit faire face à une
nouvelle concurrence
la presse gratuite des journaux comme 20
minutes et métro apparaissent dans la
capitale colère des kiosquiers qui
aimeraient aussi pouvoir les distribuer
ça ferait toujours à portée des gens et
ça nous permettrait de vendre aussi par
exemple de distribuer un gratuit et de
vente d'officiels ça amènerait les gens
sur le lieu de vente
évidemment et qui ose qui doivent
affronter un autre problème ils sont
obligés de proposer à la vente toutes
les publications dont certaines ne se
vante jamais ou presque ça on n'a jamais
vendu à un jeune écologiste je me
souviens pas d'avoir déjà vendu ça leur
prend part et ça vaut 6 euros 80 ça se
vend comme les cercueils à deux places
la situation se détériore un peu plus
avec l'arrivée de la presse sur internet
dans les années 2000 pour vivre les
clauses qui sont obligés de se
diversifier à l'image de nelly qui
travaille à saint germain des prés la
presse ne paye que mes vendeurs donc moi
si je veux me faire un salaire je suis
obligé aussi même dans un point de vente
comme celui ci de développer des
produits diversification ou des produits
de touristes pour pouvoir vivre moi du
métier grève des transports gilet jaune
et maintenant le coc vide depuis deux
ans la profession ces prises toutes les
crises de plein fouet
entre 2000 et 2020 le nombre de kiosques
parisiens est passée de 418 à 364 soit
54 de moins
[Musique]